welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can watch just
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go along
with this video check out the link in
the description below alright so today
is bonus day number one and we're gonna
learn how to have more balanced how do
you go about establishing that work/life
balance that everybody you know talks
about and thinks about you've got yummy
you live a big life right I know how do
you how do you
I get developed in a lot I get it I
teach senior executive kind of
leadership classes at Amazon for our
most senior execs and I also teach or
not teach but I also speak to interns so
kind of all across the spectrum and I
get this question about work-life
balance all the time from from both ends
of the spectrum and the my view is I
don't even like the phrase work-life
balance I think it's misleading I like
the phrase work life harmony because I
know that if I am energized at work
happy at work
feeling like I'm adding value part of a
team whatever energizes you that makes
me better at home it makes me a better
husband a better father and likewise if
I'm happy at home it makes me a better
employee a better boss all the things
it's not about it's not primarily about
there may be crunch periods where it's
about the number of hours in the week
but that that's not the that's not the
real thing
usually it's about do you have energy
and is this is your work depriving you
of energy or is your work generating
energy for you and you know there are
people everybody in this room notice
people you fall into these two camps
you're in a meeting and the person comes
in the room some people come into the
meeting and they add energy to the
meeting other people come into the
meeting and the whole meeting just
deflates and those people just
they drain energy from the meeting and
you have to decide which was host of
people you're gonna be are you gonna add
energy same thing at home and the same
thing at home and it's so it's a wheel
it's a cycle it's a flywheel it's a
circle it's not a balance because of
balance that's why that metaphor is so
dangerous because it implies there's a
strict trade-off and you could be out of
work have all the time for your family
in the world but really depressed and
demoralized about your work situation
and your family wouldn't want to be
anywhere near you they would wish you
would take a vacation from them and so
it's not about the number of hours not
primarily I suppose if you went crazy
with you know 100 hours a week or
something yeah that right maybe there
are limits and the private but I've
never had a problem and I think it's
because both sides of my life give me
energy and that's what I would recommend
that's what I do recommend to interns
and execs I believe in work-life
integration I don't think and I might be
disrespectful to oh no no yeah I want to
hear but I'm saying everybody has a
different metaphor I'm telling my
metaphor I'm not making somebody wrong
focus my balance but to me if you say
balance it's like okay let's use a
teeter-totter or a seesaw
okay we're gonna let's balance it now
now that we've done that how long are we
gonna stand there balancing this thing
before one of us wants to jerk this
thing around just to feel alive right
yeah so I really think balance is is
more about integration for me it's more
about like how do I make sure that I
feel like the errors of my life my wife
my children my grandchildren my health
sports
I got 31 companies I got 1,200 employees
and seven radically different industries
we do five billion a year
I mean it's so all these things are
going on how do I do that
well I believe that the way I do that as
a streaks that he streaks of
unbelievable intensity work and I just
reeks of like let go and being you know
paradise and enjoy and so I like
hi I wanna I want at the end happy climb
in the amount that's just me so I'm not
saying that track for other people I'm
saying gotta find what it is but the
idea of balance for most people makes
them torture themselves and I fade for
me
it departures you get rid of it and
instead of saying Tocqueville innovation
I asked Mary Callahan eros who's if
you're not familiar with her she's
probably the one of if not the smartest
person in the financial world female
she's ahead of JPMorgan and manages 2.3
trillion with a team out of me
trillion dollars of the money while the
nicest human being ever me breaks all
the molds on people in the financial
business there's not an ounce of
manipulation in her body
I mean just good good soul and I asked
her about the balance thing where the
biggest bank in the world right
trillions of dollars and she said
something I don't believe in it and she
told me work on founders don't laugh or
completing each other's sentences she
has the same philosophy but her dad used
to take her to work and he was a
financial guy when she was a little girl
she has to have her brother be the
secretary if she took her dad see Iran
Michelle and she said really Matt was my
dad she goes I loved it I was a part of
his life I got to be a part of see that
part he's like instead of coming home
and me not knowing it and she said
that's what she's done with her kids in
a JP Morgan she leaves and picks her
kids up and she still runs the biggest
thing the world goes trillions of
dollars so would she say it's bound
she'd say no it's not balance its
integrate she knows when to move into
one or the other right so that all the
parts of her life are rich maybe instead
of balance it's a rich life in the areas
that matter
yeah right rich with your children rich
with your husband or wife rich with your
dear friends rich with the impact that
you want to have your mission rich in
terms of successful business and or
whatever your career is that you really
feel a sense of meaning and enjoyment to
me that's more important than balance
that I think but I'm a very passionate
lazy side
balance a little boring if you're
tortured by balance trying to be
balanced I uh people are not balanced
enough instead enjoy yourself enjoy your
children enjoy the time be where you are
right now that to me is more important
trying to make everything balance
because that becomes negative cerebral
it makes you evaluate things have more
you evaluate the less you can actually
experience what's your label work-life
balance is a myth you can call it work
life integration Jeff basis calls it
work life harmony the keys that there's
never going to be a day when everything
is balanced you know 50% work 50% family
we're not talking about that we are
talking about refueling so there may be
a time when you pull an all-nighter I
mean I obviously emphasize sleep but I
have a cell all-nighters yes I mean
let's say the day before we launch
thrive we're all in the office pulling
an all-nighter the question is how
quickly do you refuel hmm the next I've
you can do it the next day or the day
after that we even in our cultural
values are thrive we have something that
we call thrive time we don't say this is
a nine-to-five job yeah there are no
interesting nine-to-five jobs what have
you guys found is your thing that kind
of allows you to balance the two like
what's groove you figured out along the
way to to at least make the best of
balancing the two of life and business
well for me be honest with you I don't
have balance I mean I don't seek it and
nor do I have it to be candid with you I
mean at any given time you know there's
certain areas of my life that are spikin
compared to other ones and I think just
the people around me know that there's
gonna be times where I'm gonna have an
abundance of time with my family there's
many times where you know I'm just going
nuts with work or whatever it is in my
life so I don't really have balance I
don't seek it I think balance is boring
and I think in people that have a ton of
balance probably aren't achieving a
whole lot or accomplishing a lot or
loving a lot like I like a little drama
I like a little intensity I like stress
and so I'm not even really after that so
I think people that are seeking that are
seeking something at least for me I
don't know how GC feels about it but for
me it's not something I want
- I know the perfect balance exists for
anybody I mean I think you're probably
pretty balanced when you're dead but you
know when I'm living and I'm alive
there's just different areas of my life
at any given time that demand more of my
time or that I'm demanding more of my
time in and so that at least for me I
don't have it
have you tried to like in your career
like tried to have it and then figured
I'll forget this it's not working or
it's not that I don't it's not that I'm
not aware but I need to invest time and
something that I have invest not that
I'm not aware of that it's just I'm not
under the illusion that I'm gonna get to
a perfect balanced state that's yeah
because I've lived long enough in I
guess what you probably call some kind
of controlled chaos
I enjoy variety I like uncertainty I
like not everything being the same every
single day you know I get asked a lot
about routines and things like that I'm
very regiment a very routine person yet
I hope there's different things in my
day different variables different things
every single day so I think if someone's
seeking balance they're probably chasing
the wrong thing at least for me that's
not what I want I don't want to be bored
I don't want to know what every day is
gonna be like and I like that life calls
me to different places and it demands me
to be great in one place over another at
any given time so I don't know about you
yeah I mean I you know I'm very similar
that I'm not I'm not
I think it's an illusion a little bit of
an illusion that somebody the seeking
balance is probably struggling in an
area maybe not winning in it and it kind
of goes along this whole theme about
when do you burn out people struggling
with burnout I've never I've been told
about numerous people I'm gonna burn out
I've been told that since I was 26 years
old you're gonna burn out and Here I am
you know 34 years later I hadn't burned
out have more energy today than I had
when I was 26 I'm not a candle I'm a
spiritual being spiritual being in their
perfect condition would not be
interested in a balance it would be
unnecessary so it's like nature it's an
estate of flow almost the spirit the
spirit itself would be able to move into
any space at any time without any
gimmicks without any preparation and and
be able to assist in the next emergency
you know I see first responders first
responders these heroes that jump into
situations that they didn't know there
was going to be a fire they didn't know
there was gonna be a 911
they didn't know that a kid was gonna be
trapped in a car they move into an event
to save a situation and and that's what
I hear ed saying like he moves into
whatever needs to move in very very much
like a liquid would mercurial to be
mobile you know to build it to be able
to move into different things this is
what financial freedom is so important
for people and it's it's what cash flow
is so important so that people can move
to their parents and help them move to a
kid in their community that needs help
and and that's why I pushed that money
message so much because when you have
enough money balance is not what you're
seeking contribution and charity if you
concentrate solely on your career you
can get a long way in your career and I
would say that that's a strategy that a
minority of men preferentially do that
that's all they do
they works like 70 80 hours a week they
go flat out on their career they're
staking everything on small probability
of exceptional status in a narrow domain
but it's it's hard on them they don't
have a life it's very difficult for them
to have a family they don't know how to
take any leisure activity like they get
very one-dimensional now it may be that
that unit dimensionality is the price
you have to pay to be exceptional at one
thing right because if you're going to
be something like a genius level
mathematician and you want to do that
for a scientist say it's like you're in
your lab you're in your lab all the time
you're working 70 hours a week or 80
hours a week you're smart you're
dedicated your unit dimensional and
that's how you get to beat all the other
people who are doing that it's the only
way but the problem is you don't get a
life now if you love being a scientist
and you have that kind of focus of mind
well first of all you're a rare person
and second you're going to pay for it
but find more power to you but but it's
a it's a risky business to do that you
sacrifice a lot for it you know and I
would say most often if you're speaking
about having a healthy life that isn't
what you do you spread yourself out more
so you know you have a family you have
some things that you do outside of work
that are meaningful to you and useful
you you have a
network of friends of that that those
three things loner four things loner
plenty to keep you well oriented and
then if one of those things collapses
you know everything doesn't go now the
price you pay for that is the more you
strive to optimize that balance the less
likely you are to be fantastically
successful at any single one of them but
you might have a very you know if you
consider your life as a whole that might
be a winning strategy one of the things
Carl Jung said I really like this
he thought that men went after
perfection and when women went after
wholeness so they're different they're
different value they're did they're
different there's something different at
the top of the value hierarchy so
perfection would be stake it all on one
thing and look for radical success not
all not that all men do that because
they don't but we're talking about
extremes and at least with regards to
the men that do that the wholeness idea
is more like well I want I want it's
like I want one thing in my life to be a
hundred and fifty percent or I want five
things in my life to be 80 percent well
there's a lot more richness in a life
where you have five things operating at
80 percent but you're not operating in
any of at any of them at a hundred and
fifty percent so and I really believe
this because I've watched men and women
go through their careers now for a long
period of time and one of the things
that there's lots of things that produce
this but one of the things that I've
noticed is that mostly women in their
30s bear bail out of uni-dimensional
careers they won't do them they won't
they won't put in the 80 hours a week
that they would have to put in in order
to dominate that particular area and it
isn't the reason that they won't do it
is because they decide it's not worth it
and no wonder because why would that be
worth it you have to ask yourself that
it's like well you want to be an
outstanding scientist it's like okay
really really that's what you want
because that means that's what you do
because you're competing with other
people you know they're smart they're
hard-working and if you want to be at
the top you have to be smarter and work
harder than any of them and working hard
means working long hours I mean it also
means working diligently but in in the
final analysis it's also an additive
issue if I'm smart and hardworking and I
can crank out for 70 hours a week and
you do it for 30 it's like in two years
I'm so far ahead of you you will never
ever catch up my biggest challenge is
balance my biggest challenge is how do I
continue to succeed and achieve on the
level that I've been going for all these
years but still be a good husband to my
wife still be a good father to my kids
yeah and and to do that it's not like
I'm good about getting home but I need
to get better about being present when
I'm on taking the phone and throwing it
in the other room under percent because
you've got the biggest artist in the
world and when they call you it you
can't just say yeah I'll work off yeah
you know so it's you want to do it -
yeah it's about finding that balance
that which I struggle with every day and
one of my favorite stories see I don't
know if I should have watched our
interview remember was that for when I
thought we got a lot of do people out
here who my wife is the founder of
cancer mmm
and now she has a new thing she's also
doing called mother lucker right on land
yeah and one day I came home and um you
know we were we were going through some
really rough with with one of my clients
and about four days in a row I was
coming home I'm stressed out I kept
bringing it to bed I'm stressed out and
stressed out could bring it to bed
finally my wife on like the fourth or
fifth night she gets up and she goes you
can't keep bringing this home to bed
she's like I don't need this energy yeah
and in a classic obnoxious entertainment
I make you know money way mmm
I looked at my wife and said you know
that's unfair for you say that to me you
know how do you think I provide this
life you know this is what I do for a
living you knew what you got when you
signed up it's like this is you can't
like you have to respect like I'm not
doing this for me this isn't selfish I'm
working hard for other people and my
wife looked at me and she goes okay well
I've been helping someone with chemo for
the last week should I bring that home
mmm and you talk about a shut
got moment Wow instantly a couple things
happened number one I realized why I
married her why I'm madly in love with
this woman to which I've said many times
before she reminded me that what I deal
with is inconveniences what she deals
with his problems
mm-hmm and that helped me with balance
understanding what's really important
and what's bull right you know and when
you have children that helps even more
because all you want to do is get back
to your kids and be present with them is
they don't care no matter who you are
what you do and they don't know these
people my kids wants play
hide-and-go-seek
yeah just draw off his paper he doesn't
care wants to play hot daddy run I'm a
daddy run come back in the room i'ma
hiding that is the game that is life
right now and uh you know I I just I
think what's important to me also with
balance is that I really do want to be
someone that people in my industry look
at I want to change the paradigm you
know when I came in it was fast women
fast cars you know bottle bottle like
that see when people think about it and
I want to challenge old and I've been a
part of a lot of big records and a lot
of big artists some people know some
people don't even know and I want to
change it so when people come to
business they say who's the baddest dude
here they see someone who is family
first you are known as one of the nicest
most pleasant people in show business
which also really big boss that gets a
lot of things done so how do you balance
being nice and having to lay the
SmackDown
there's a few things I always try and
find make sure that I find time every
day to be grateful for everything that I
have when you start off our days finding
things to be grateful for and inevitably
leads to a greater happiness so every
day I wake up I'm a grateful man for
everything that I have but I'm also very
quick to make sure that when something
needs to get done and you have to either
articulate it to somebody else and you
have to set a protocol and you have to
set parameters and you have to lay the
smack then you got to do it in the firm
way I do in a kind way but I also do in
the firm way and when it comes to laying
the smackdown if anybody's rude or if
anybody is treating other people rudely
or unkindly I'll happily step in and
they don't want any bit of this all
right don't let this smile fool you
because this is 260 pounds of kick
somebody's ass around and I want to
share with you a piece of advice that
one of my mentors gave me a few years
ago he sat me down actually I was
already sitting he sat down next to me
and he said I get that you're struggling
right now honey at the time I was going
through a problem and he said Sean you
got to remember this life is a delicate
balance from one end remaining flexible
and on the other hand enforcing your
boundaries and it was so simple that I
almost discarded it that advice just
sounded trite click right flexible yet
boundaries and he further explained that
you got to remain flexible life is going
to change on you but you also have to
enforce your boundaries you got to let
other people know in the universe know
what you will and will not tolerate and
he said if you get to was the words he
said if you get too flexible you can be
manipulated and walked on
if you get too much in the space of
enforcing your boundaries you'll become
cold hard and distant where people
aren't going to want to love you work
with you hang out with you you need a
balance when I looked at my life and I
thought well where am I
gravitating towards naturally well my
whole life I've had to remain flexible
I'm three feet on in a wheelchair I have
you know a condition by the time I
turned 18 I had fractured over 200 times
something like going to the airport on a
family vacation and I break my arm
putting my jack on and now we can't go
you know all these things happen in my
life that forced me become flexible
handle whatever comes at you but when it
came to enforcing boundaries sometimes I
wasn't strong enough and sometimes I
would tolerate things in relationships
in business partnerships they didn't
agree with ready to rock the boat can
you relate but not everybody's like me
some people will get really good at
enforcing their boundaries making it
very clear what they will and won't
tolerate they have a hard time and you
like you move one little thing on their
desk or you change one thing about their
life
or you need them to compromise on
something and they freak out
they can't handle uncertainty they can't
handle dealing with other people's
schedules whatever it may be they just
have a hard time being flexible with
life and you need to think about where
are you naturally gravitating because
it's time to move yourself more towards
the middle if you've gotten really good
at enforcing your boundaries
congratulations
that's awesome you're not gonna be
messed with but maybe you're very hard
to deal with or meeting you're like the
most flexible person on earth everybody
loves you you're the nice girl a nice
guy but you can walked all over and you
have no self-respect now
is you get manipulated and pushed in or
maybe you were one and then swung the
pendulum so far to the other side that
you've lost your original space the goal
is to find that center point it's to
find that I like it graceful dance as my
mentor called it a dance between
remaining flexible than forcing your
boundaries so next time you're having a
challenge with someone or in your own
life just by yourself ask yourself am I
too strict with my boundaries am i
laying down a lot too much and making it
uncomfortable for people to deal with me
or am I too flexible my too
accommodating am i making all kinds of
concessions and getting walked on or
abused figure out what is it for you
keep the two in balance in your life or
flow most often if not always and life
seem to be out of balance and when lives
are out of balance it makes us very
irritable you know when we drive a car
we always drive a car and a car has four
wheels a rhetorical thing to say isn't
it you drive a car on these four wheels
and these four wheels in the car of life
represent first.we your personal life
your health your mind yourself the
things that you love to do the things
that you would want to do not have to do
most times we live a life of have to do
I have to study I have to work I have to
pay my bills I have to pay the taxes I
have to do this and I have to do that I
have to go for the social function I
don't have a choice
I have to have to have to have to where
did the love to go we just end up living
a life of half dues and I forgot about
our own cells by subscribing to the
pressures that come from all fronts in
our lives we've forgotten to live our
own lives we don't have time to unwind
we don't have time to spend with our own
selves we don't have time to be with
nature and take
deep breath and just relish the
crispness of the air we don't have the
time to do all of that especially in the
metropolitan city like this when the
pressures are so high and the pace is so
fast we just don't have time for
ourselves ladies and gentleman and
that's one car one wheel of our car
isn't it personal life a health for
instance such an important thing but at
the cost of just running if you forget
to pay attention to our own health the
second wheel of the car is family life
demands attention isn't it your personal
life demands attention
your family life demands attention isn't
it before marriage when you are in love
they call it a crush isn't it but after
marriage all that is left is candy crush
all the crushes are in gone and all that
you're left with is a candy crush and
all the headaches coming from all the
pressures one lady went to a doctor and
the doctor said how's your headache
madam she said he is out of town gosh I
must tell you
demands a lot of attention your personal
life the first tire do you have one do
you have a personal life is my question
do you have time for your health
even in my hectic schedule I have made
five days of exercise yes still in all
the lectures and all the talks and
everywhere I go because that's what's
going to keep me going I have to give
time to myself because I don't get more
than three and a half to four hours of
sleep so if I don't look at my physical
fitness I'm gone ladies and gentlemen do
you give time for yourself do you have
time for yourself your personal time or
is that wheel out of balance is that a
flat tire the third we tire of the car
of life is your professional life your
personal life needs attention
your family life needs attention your
professional life needs attention and
the fourth is your social life your
friends people around you your
colleagues those relationships that
matter a lot to you those people who
would support you in time of need
because to your spouses to your family
you could speak a little sometimes
certain things are not always confided
with just blood relationships you need
that social side people to me we can
speak open up your heart
how often do we just carry this baggage
of stress and load anxiety and worry in
our heads lugging it all around us
baggage this is social side to our life
a friends you know I have had those
moments where I've snapped even as a
monk because I'm a human being just
because I put this robes of a monk
doesn't mean I become you know a
celestial angel I'm still a human being
when one of those tires is out of order
if I haven't slept well if my health is
out of place I'm going to snap out you
know you carry work pressures at home
you carry home pressures at work ladies
in German irritability is a symptom of
an out of balance life stability in our
responses is a symptom of a life in
balance we are irritable we snap we
react at the drop of a hat for trivia
just because we are out of balance
people who have a balanced life know how
to handle pressure people whose lives
are not balanced sink under pressure and
get so irritable at little things they
just kind of snap off now I've got a
special bonus clip that I think you can
enjoy but before that it's time for the
best live 30 questions
day it's not enough to just watch a
video like this you have to do something
and take action in your life so pull out
your worksheets and answer these
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets yet you can get them for free
by signing up for the series in the
description below here we go question
number 1 what does a balanced life look
like for you number two what's the first
change you need to make to get more in
balance and number three how does your
next month need to change to match your
definition of balance and if you're
doing the best life 30 challenge with me
give me a hashtag best life 30 down the
comments as well so I can celebrate you
I think if you have a partner who
doesn't support your business you're
either gonna lose your business you're
going to lose your partner it's really
hard to be mission driven and want to
have a successful company and being a
relationship with somebody who doesn't
support you I think there's four buckets
that people fall into two of them are
negative and two of them are positive
the two on the negative side you have a
partner who just absolutely hates what
you're doing you have a partner who just
doesn't believe in what you're doing
they hate it they think you should quit
they think it's tearing down the family
they just don't want you to do anything
with related to that business and that
really sucks as a place to be you can't
continue on with your business and your
relationship you have to figure out a
way to make it happen the second bucket
is they tolerate it they're not happy
with it but they tolerate it and that's
also a really tough place to be because
any time you are struggling any time
you're not getting results any time
you're coming home when you're stressed
out they're gonna say see see I told you
that business you shouldn't be doing it
they barely tolerate it but they're not
on your side they just do it because
they want you to have your thing and
they love you but they're not really on
your side they don't want it to succeed
it's a really hard spot to be in if
that's you and an entrepreneur and that
being your partner it sucks
now we move into the positive side the
next step up as they support you they
support you they believe in what you're
doing they may not be involved in it but
they want you to be happy they believe
in your mission there they're pumped
that you're up doing your own thing and
they support you and you going off and
accomplishing your goal and then the
last one which is ideal in most
situations if you have
one who's a champion and they champion
you and they want to be involved and and
wanna help and they want to participate
and they're thinking about you and
they're they're trying to champion your
cause and so there's four buckets you
have to be in the last two in my opinion
you have to be in a positive territory
with your partner otherwise your
relationship or your business will not
last long term so what can you do now
how can you move your partner from being
the negative spot to being a more
positive one I'm gonna give you a three
step process that I think will help your
business and your relationship it looks
like this support communicate involve
support communicate and involve so step
one is support and what that means is
you support them support them first if
you are supporting them in their career
and their ambitions and their drive and
what they're looking for you're much
more likely get support back on you if
you were just expecting support 24/7 but
you're not giving it first it's really
hard so if you want to get it back you
want to receive start by giving and so
they may not want to be an entrepreneur
that may not be how you support them but
could you support them in their career
could you support them in their
friendships could you support them in
your relationship like what are they
after
what are their goals what are their
aspirations what do they need help with
do they just need somebody to come home
and listen to them for half an hour when
they walk in the door what is it what
does the port look like for them not
your version of it you know what you
want what's their version of it and how
can you support them in accomplishing
their goals their ambitions their
aspirations you support them first and
then you'll get a little more support on
your rent that promise step number two
is communicate one of the biggest
challenges with entrepreneurs is we
don't often communicate to our partners
what we're going through or thinking
about struggling with and this is
something that that Nina and I
struggling with early on in our
relationship
Nina's where's Nina you know somewhere
there Nina's somewhere there there's the
hand so me I don't need to share what's
happening in my life I don't need to
doesn't doesn't release any stress or
attention or energy if I'm working with
something I need to just figure it out
and Adele get to the place where I have
an answer and I'm good
Nina always wants to know what's
happening in my life she wanted to know
when she came home from work what
happened with me that day I don't leave
her
brought out with me that day I have to
force myself to think about what
happened and at the beginning that
caused a little bit of tension and so I
made a dedicated effort to say okay I'm
gonna think about what's happening in my
life was happening my business I'm gonna
make an effort to tell Nina first before
anybody else finds out she'd be upset if
she wasn't the first to know so I make
her the first to know and that extra
communication helps because she
understands my world a little bit better
even though she wasn't involved in my
world that want you to know she didn't
know much about YouTube or the things
that I'm working on
she couldn't be an asset to the business
yet just having her know having her feel
like she's involved in the problems that
I'm facing at that time make everything
easier so there was an important YouTube
update that came out her or something
went wrong on the channel and she knew
about it she would say hey do you need
to go home and work on it she
understands now she's in my corner so
it's not the business being the negative
the business taking time away from us my
problem has become her problem and my
win has become her win and so it allows
her an entry point into my world and so
communicate you have to communicate you
got to set the rules you got to explain
what's going on I did an event yesterday
in Indianapolis and an entrepreneur came
up at the end and was talking to me
about how he feels the same way where
he's like super stressed out at work and
his business and he comes home and he
has no more energy left and then he
comes and his wife wants to talk
immediately about what happened to him
during the day and he just wants some
time to relax and it causes a lot of
tension at home and he's a frustrated
upset that he's not bringing his best of
himself at home to his relationships so
give him some advice one on your way
home go with the intention of how do you
want the rest of your evening to go
right you're just going home like an
accident go home with the intention if I
want to have a great night with my wife
to work on communicate and explain if
you're stressed out say why you're
stressed out don't take it out on your
partner go home and say what happened to
you and why you're so stressed out and
by you explaining it you're bringing her
into your world she's more like than
understand and support you that's how
you can get somebody from touches
tolerating what you're doing to
supporting you because they see how
important it is to you and the
storytelling brings them into your
and then three just a communication on
that part of maybe you need 20 minutes
to yourself when you come home maybe you
set some ground rules with your wife and
say hey I I want to tell you everything
I want to explain and be fully
transparent and let you to my world when
I come home I just need 20 minutes to
myself just to decompress just to relax
and then I'm in a much better spot
emotionally to be able to come and talk
and share what's on my mind
chances are actually to understand that
but you just set that up you set that
communication up before so that when you
come home it's not this giant fight
every night so step two and building a
better relationship is communication and
then step number three is involving them
see what you can do to involve them into
your business into your mission into
your values if there's a fit so I'm
filming this from an air B&B here in
Indianapolis I made a commitment to my
wife and I said I'm gonna take you to
every city in North America with a
million plus people I did that cuz she
liked to travel and I like mean
entrepreneurs so how about we combine
these things together Nina loves
organizing events she loves putting on
events doing all the all the detail work
all that stuff that I'm not a huge fan
of but I didn't have a lot for her to do
in my business right she didn't want to
be in front of the camera she didn't
want to do YouTube stuff organizing
events was not a big part of what I did
I do two events a year in Toronto one in
May 1 to September teaching people how
to be thought leaders and make money
from it and she definitely helped out a
lot in putting those events on and
booked in the restaurants and all of
that stuff she was a huge lifesaver but
it's not enough to be heavily involved
it's definitely not a full-time job so I
said well what if we found the way to
integrate it what if we combined your
love of travel in your love of
organizing events my love of helping
entrepreneurs and we smush all that
together and we created this tour we
created this Frankenstein creation where
her I'm visiting in 90 days 23 different
cities and that was a cold collaboration
right that was a Coe effort on our part
to combine our wishes together what we'd
love doing and find a way to work
together what's gonna happen you do the
90 days I don't know does need to go
back and get another job I don't know
there's Nina find another path to
continue on in my business I don't know
we're gonna be different people by the
end of the 90 days and so we're open to
be able to do more together and so
following that three-step process
thinking about how first you can support
them on what they're doing then thinking
about how you can communicate better
just to express what you're going
through and then three trying to figure
out how can you involve them more in
what you're doing not forcing them to do
something that they don't want to do by
finding an opportunity of how they can
combine their passion with your mission
as well I think makes for a much better
work-life integration and a happier
relationship as well as a business if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge and get the free worksheets
click the link right here below me or if
you want more videos on how to have more
balance in your life check out the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you soon